Celine Dion gives us life posing like a
pro in Paris it makes me feel very proud
[Music]
take note to supermodels the iconic
singer went to work during a Thursday
afternoon photoshoot and we are loving
every second of it the 49 year old
mother of three flaunted her best angles
rocking a stylish gray tweed skirt with
a matching coat complete with this ultra
chic wide brim tap today was a good day
Celine who is known for her outgoing
showmanship didn't hold back for the
camera exaggerating her twirls giving
face with some pruning shears and
serving up some major moments it's a lot
of work the music legend is in Paris for
Fashion Week and was photographed
looking super glam at the Dior show with
Vogue's editor-in-chief Anna Wintour in
between shows she stripped down for the
mag and posed in the buff hashtag slay
Celine opened up to et in 2016
about upping her fashion game with the
help of famed stylist la roche he said
girl come out of your closet so rub me
out of my closet and now flowers are
growing
[Music]
you
[Music]